[Applause]
anger on the streets of hambantota in
southern sri lanka the heartland of the
governing rajapaksa family farmers here
say the government's move to make
farming 100 organic threatens their
livelihood
the government wants us to listen to
ministers not agricultural experts but
experts say this won't work
the government banned the import of
fertilizers and other agricultural
chemicals earlier this year after a
foreign currency shortage it wants
farmers to use organic alternatives
across the country in poland one of the
biggest rice producing areas 81 year old
devatar pali gunatunga is impatient
his peripherals are overgrown
normally he says the soil would be
tilled and ready by now
when you stop supplies all of a sudden
whether it's vegetables aubergines or
chilies they have worms potatoes don't
grow properly these products are
essential this is why farmers are angry
president gotabe rajapaksa says the
change is needed to reduce the health
risks posed by agricultural chemicals
rather than seeking political mileage
everyone should get together and do this
for our country for our future
generations we can do this in a short
time it won't take 10 or 15 years
many scientists agricultural experts and
successful organic farmers like cow
dooley jaithisa disagree
he says it's taken him 12 years to turn
around this green patch
destroying something can be done quickly
but reviving it has to be done
systematically and in a very organized
way that's why i say the government
could get farmers more involved give
them incentives seek their views and
consult others in green agriculture that
would have been more successful
attempts to secure organic fertilizer
have run into a series of problems the
sri lankan government says farmer
protests like this are instigated by the
opposition and multinational chemical
and fertilizer companies but tens of
thousands of farmers facing crop
failures and lower yields
say they are facing a battle for
survival
for now the farmers say their biggest
concern is how they will feed their
families in the coming months
miner fernandez al-jazeera polo naru
north central sri lanka